The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: So I should
probably get started.
So I just wanted to mention
this Friday the libraries are
having Furry Friday.
So they have therapy dogs
come, and if you like dogs,
it's kind of fun to go
get cuddled by the dog.
The other thing I wanted
to mention, last term,
there was a student taking
3032 who was interested in art.
And I kept trying to find
art pictures for him,
and he's not here.
But I thought everybody
else can like the art too.
So I belong to the Peabody
Essex Museum in Salem, Mass.
And they have an
exhibit right now
on wood and on sort of using
wood as a sculptural material.
And this is one of their
posters to advertise it.
So this thing was carved out
of a single piece of wood,
I think.
And they've got lots of other
sort of sculptural wood.
So I thought you might
like to see that.
If you wanted to go to Salem,
there's a couple of options,
if you don't have a car.
You can take a
commuter rail to Salem.
You can also take the ferry.
And if you take
the ferry to Salem,
it's like a five minute walk
to where the ferry lets you off
to get to the Peabody Essex.
And it's a kind of neat museum.
It's not too big.
It's kind of small.
But it's a beautiful building,
and they have neat stuff there.
So you could go to the
Peabody Essex Museum.
Hmm?
STUDENT: It's very nice.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
you've been there?
Yeah, it's really nice.
So I was going to talk about
honeycomb-like materials
in nature today.
And I'm going to talk
about wood today,
and I might finish this today.
I might not.
And then I'm going
to talk about cork
for a little bit on
Wednesday, and then we'll
start talking about
foams after that.
So I have a couple of sort
of cute little language
historically things.
And you know how I
like that stuff too.
So I have two things about
words that are related to wood.
So the word "materials--"
you know where
the word materials comes from?
It comes from the Latin.
So there's a Latin
"materies materia."
And materies
materia means "wood"
or "the trunk of a tree."
So if you think of studying
materials, in olden times
that was like studying wood.
And another cute thing that
I found was that in old Irish
the names of the first few
letters of the alphabet
are named after trees.
So the letter A, that's
called alem in old Irish,
and alem is the word for elm.
And B is-- I don't know
if I'm saying these right.
It's called beith, and
that's the word for birch.
And C is call.
That's the word for hazel.
And D is dair, and
that's the word for oak.
And so they sort of named
the letters of the alphabet
after different kinds of trees,
different kinds of woods.
So I just thought
those were kind
of interesting
historical things.
So I wanted to start by
talking about wood structure.
And then we're going
to look at how would
deforms and fails, and
talk about the data
that people have
measured for the wood
properties, things like
stiffness and strength.
And then we'll talk a little bit
about how the honeycomb models
can be applied to understanding
the mechanical properties
of woods.
So this is kind of a generic
trunk of the tree here.
And we're defining three axes.
The radial axis comes
radially out of the tree.
There's the tangential axis, so
that's the x1 and the x2 axes.
And then there's
the longitudinal
or the axial axis, x3.
So if you think of
the wood as being,
in a very, very simple way,
just like the honeycomb,
the radial would be this way on.
The tangent would
be that way on.
And that axial would
So it's like that.
And if you neglect
the growth rings,
you can say that other
woods orthotropic,
and that's typically
what people do.
They neglect the
growth rings, and they
say that it's orthotropic.
And the density of the
woods, the relative density
ranges from about 5% for
balsa wood to about 80%
for lignum vitae.
So I brought in
some pieces of wood.
So this is balsa wood.
You're probably familiar,
making different kinds
of models with balsa.
So balsa's very light.
It grows in Ecuador.
And it's the lightest wood.
And this is lignum vitae.
You're probably not
so familiar with that.
This actually grows in Florida,
and it's the densest wood.
It has a relative
density of 0.8.
And it's so dense, that if
you put it in water, it sinks.
So it's a very dense wood.
And the way the
wood cells grow is
that if you look at the sort
of structure here of a tree,
there's the bark on
the outside here,
and then there's the kind of
wood cells inside the bark.
And there's a layer of
cells in between the bark
and the wood called
cambial layer.
And that's really the
layer of cells that
are alive and are dividing.
So if you think
of the wood cells,
they're living when they're
in that little cambial layer
there.
And they're dividing.
And that cambial
layer, the cells
have a plasma membrane
and a protoplast.
And then they sort of
exude the plant cell wall.
So a little like bone
cells, like if you
think of the bone in
your body, there's
osteoblasts and osteoclasis,
different kinds of bone cells.
But the bone cells secrete
the sort of collagen
and the calcium
phosphate that are
the sort of hard mineral part
of the bone that you think about
in the bone.
And that's not a living thing.
The cells are the living thing.
That's like an
extracellular matrix.
In the trees, it's a
little bit the same.
So there's the living cells
that are just under the bark,
and they have this plasma
membrane and the protoplasm.
And over a few weeks they
excrete the plant cell wall,
and then they die.
So the living cells
die, and you're
left with the plant cell walls.
And then as the
tree grows, you're
always having a layer
of these cambial cells,
and it forms bark on the
outside and wood on the inside.
So there's sort of a layer of
cells that are differentiated,
such that on the outer
layer they form the bark,
and on the inner layer
they form the wood.
And as the tree grows,
that cambial layer
is kind of expanding
out radially.
So let me write some
of these things down.
Let's see.
So let me just write down
those two little word things
because I think they're cute.
So the word materials is from
the Latin materies materia.
And that means "wood" or
the "trunk of a tree."
And here's the little
old Irish thing.
It's not like I think--
I'm not going to put
this on the test or something.
I just thought it was cute.
So the letter A is
alem, which is elm.
And letter B is
beith, which is birch.
Letter C is call.
That's hazel.
And D was dair, and that's oak.
So that's just for
general interest.
So then the wood structure we
can think of it as orthotropic,
if we ignored the growth rings.
And if you have a sort
of large diameter tree
and you take a piece of wood
not from the very center,
but from somewhere
near the outside,
then that's not a
bad approximation.
Now, the relative
density of the woods
ranges from about 0.05 for balsa
to about 0.8 for lignum vitae.
Any Latin scholars here?
I took one year of
Latin in high school.
Anybody take Latin?
No, no Latin.
So I think lignum vitae I
think is "tree of life."
"Vitae" is the sort of life.
And when it has this ending
A-E it means "of life."
So I think that's the "tree
of life" is lignum vitae.
So trees have cambial
layer beneath the bark.
And the cell division occurs
in that cambial layer.
So the new cells on the
outer part turn into bark,
and the new cells on the
inner part turn into wood.
And then we have the
living plant cells
that have the plasma
membrane and the protoplast.
And those cells then
secret the plant cell wall,
which sort of surrounds them.
So in trees, the living cells
lay down the plant cell wall
over a period of a few weeks.
And then the living cells die.
Oops.
Back.
Here.
Now you always retain a
layer of those cambial cells.
So you may have heard
if you have a tree
and you cut a ring around
the tree through the bark,
if you go into
those cambial cells
and you destroy them,
you kill the tree,
because you're killing
that layer of living cells.
So then we want to look at the
cellular structure of the woods
as well.
And I've got a couple
of slides here.
This one is of softwoods.
And softwoods have
two types of cells.
That have tracheids, which are
the bulk of the cells here,
and the tracheids provide
structural support.
And the tracheids
also have little holes
along the length of them
at their ends called pits,
and those pits allow fluid
transport up and down the tree.
And then the softwood also
has these ray cells here.
So those are examples
of ray cells.
So this is a transverse section.
This is a longitudinal
section here.
And the rays are parenchyma
cells which store sugars.
So softwoods have
tracheids and rays.
And then hardwoods, here's
an example of a hardwood oak.
They have three types of cells.
There's cells called fibers,
so these guys all in here
would be fibers.
They provide the
structural support.
They have vessels,
these really large cells
that provide fluid transport
up and down the tree.
And they also have rays.
So here are some rays here.
And again, those rays
are parenchyma cells
that store sugars in the tree.
So let me just write down
what all these cells are.
So in softwoods
most of the cells
are these tracheids,
so they make up
the bulk of the tree,
something like 90% of the tree.
And they provide
structural support.
They have holes in the cell
wall for fluid transport,
and those are called pits.
And to give you some idea
of what size they are,
they're are a few millimeters
long, so something like 2
and 1/2 to seven
millimeters long.
And then they're tens of microns
in the other two directions,
so they're something like
20 to 80 microns across.
And the cell wall thickness,
t, is usually a few microns,
so something between about
two and seven microns.
So typically, the
denser the wood,
the thicker the cell
wall's going to be.
Whoops, let's see if I can
get the rays down here.
Put it on the same board.
So the rays are parenchyma
cells that store sugar.
And then the hardwoods
have three types of cells.
They have the fibers that
provide the structural support.
And the amount of
cells that are fibers
varies, depending
on the species,
but it's usually somewhere
around 35% to 70% of the cells.
And then they the vessels,
which are the sap channels.
That provides for the
conduction of fluids.
And that's between about
6% and 55% of the cells.
And then, again, there's
rays that store sugars,
and they usually make a boat
10% to 30% of the cells.
So there's the structure of
this sort of cellular structure,
at this kind of length
scale of tens of microns.
And then there's
also a structure
within the cell wall itself.
And the cell wall itself is
made up of cellulose fibrils
in a matrix of lignin and
something called hemicellulose.
So if you look at the
cellulose structure,
the cellulose has a
regular structure,
a sort of periodic lattice.
And it's crystalline for most
of the length of the fibrils.
So this is the structure
of the cellulose here,
and this is showing it at a
slightly larger length scale.
It might have a crystalline
region here and then
a non-crystalline region here.
And these macro fibrils,
which are made up
of bundles of micro fibrils,
are about 10 to 25 nanometers.
And each one of
the micro fibrils
might be three to four
nanometers across.
So you have these
cellulose fibers.
And then the cell wall is
made up of different layers.
So there's what's called
the primary wall here,
which has a random arrangement
of the cellulose fibrils.
Then there's an
outer layer here.
These are all called
secondary layers.
This is S-- I think that's S1.
Yeah, it's S1.
And it has this
arrangement of the fibrils.
Then there's a layer called
S2, and it's generally
the thickest layer
in the cell wall.
And the cellulose fibrils are
aligned not perfectly vertical,
but a little off the vertical.
And the angle
between the vertical
and the orientation of
the cellulose fibers
is called the microfibril angle.
And then there's a
third layer here, S3,
with, again, a different
winding of the fibers.
So because S2 layer
is the thickest layer
and because the fibrils are
closest to the vertical axis,
the S2 layer
actually contributes
the most to the longitudinal
modulus and stiffness
and strength of the cell wall.
So that's kind of the
arrangement of the cell wall.
And then so that one
cell would have that.
Another cell would have that.
And in between the
two, there's a layer
called the middle lamella that
kind of glues them together.
So that's the
arrangement of the cells.
Let me scoot over here.
So the cells are often modeled
as a fiber reinforced composite
that has four layers to it.
And in each layer there's
different volume fraction
of the fibers and different
orientation of the fibers.
So the cell wall has this
fiber-reinforced structure.
Here's the cellulose
fibers in a matrix
of lignin and hemicellulose.
And there's four layers,
each with the fibers
in a different orientation.
And then there's the middle
lemella between the two cells.
So in doing the modeling
of a material like wood,
you need to know what the
properties of the cell wall
material are, because,
obviously, the properties
of the wood would depend on
the cell wall properties.
And it turns out
that they're similar.
They're not exactly
the same, but they're
similar in different
species of wood,
so we're going to call
them more or less the same.
So the density of the
solid is 1,500 kilograms
per cubic meter.
The modulus of the solid
in the axial direction
is 35 gigapascals.
The modulus in the tangential
direction or transverse
direction is 10 gigapascals.
And the strength of the
solid in the axial direction
is 350 megapascals.
And the strength of the
transverse direction
is about 135.
So here A means Axial
direction, and T is transverse.
And just for comparison, if
you just look at cellulose,
cellulose has some pretty
amazing properties.
The modulus of cellulose is
about 140 gigapascals, which
is very high for a polymer.
And the strength
of cellulose fibers
run between about 700
and 900 megapascals.
So the cellulose fibers have
very impressive properties.
And that's one of the
things that gives wood
very good properties.
So the next thing
is I want to show
you some stress-strain
curves for wood.
And you'll see how similar
they are to the honeycombs
that we looked at before.
And then we'll look at how
the cells are deforming
as they're getting loaded.
And from that, we're
going to do some modeling.
So let me just wait till
people get caught up.
Are we caught up?
More or less?
OK.
So these are all
compression curves,
so I'm just going to
talk about compression.
So these are curves for
different types of woos.
And on the left,
the wood is loaded
in the tangential direction.
So in terms of the sort
of honeycomb model,
it's loading at kind of
this way on, like that.
And on the right, are a
set of curves for wood load
it in axial compression.
So in axial compression loading,
we're loading it that way on.
And we've got
different species here.
So the lowest density is balsa,
around about 100 kilograms
per cubic meter.
The densest species
on this plot is
beech, which is around 700
kilograms per cubic meter.
And then there's pine and
willow, some other species in
between here.
So you can see the shapes of the
curve look just like the curves
that we had for the honeycombs.
So here there's a
linear elastic bit.
There's a stress plateau.
And there's a densification bit.
And then, as the density
goes up, it gets stiffer,
and the strain at which
the densification occurs
gets smaller, and the
strength gets higher.
And if we look at
the axial properties,
the shape of the
curve is similar.
We get linear elastic stress
plateau densification.
But if you look
at the scale here,
this scale goes from 0 to
100, whereas that scale
went from 0 to 20.
And so the stiffness and
the strength along the grain
are much higher than they
are across the grain.
And you probably
already know that.
Wood is stronger and
stiffer along the grain
than across the grain.
So that's what the stress-strain
curves looked like.
And the fact that we're
getting the curves that
look like that
makes us think maybe
the mechanisms of
deformation and failure
are similar to the
honeycomb, too.
So here's a set of
curves for balsa
all plotted on the same scale.
And, again, you can see for
loading across the grain,
either in the radial or
the tangential direction,
the stiffness and
the strength is
a lot less than if you load
it in the axial direction.
So a number of years ago,
we had a project on balsa.
And the thing we were
interested in doing
was looking at how the
cells deformed and failed.
And because balsa's
a low-density wood,
it was easier to see the
deformation in the cells,
because the cells were thin.
So that's why we chose balsa.
I actually have a project
on balsa right now.
And [? Sardar ?], my postdoc,
is doing more detailed kind
of finite [INAUDIBLE]
modeling, trying to represent
the structure of balsa.
And I think I
mentioned, the reason
we're interested in
it is the balsa's
used as a core in sandwich
panels in wind turbine blades.
It's actually the best
material that they can find,
it's better than any
engineering material.
So that's comparing the
three curves for balsa.
And then if you look
at a specimen that's
loaded in the [? SCM ?],
with a loading stage,
you can measure the
stress-strain curve,
and you can take
photographs of what
the cellular structure looks
like at different stages
of loading.
So here, this picture
one, is unloaded.
And these four images
here are looking
at the same section of cells,
the same area of cells.
And you can see there's
a big vessel here,
and that's the
same vessel there.
So here, this image
two, is at this point
on the stress-strain curve.
Here's three, at that point.
And four is at that point.
So if you look at
this carefully--
and I've got another higher
mag picture I'll show you
in a second-- you can
see that what's happening
is the cell walls are bending.
So it's kind of like taking
my honeycomb like this,
and I'm doing that to
it, and the cell walls
are bending, so just the
same as the honeycomb.
And then eventually,
if I load it enough,
you get to this sort
of densified stage.
And you're doing this, and
the stress-strain curve
increases sharply.
So here you can see how the
cells have densified over here.
It kind of looks a
lot like my honeycomb
when I-- maybe I
do it this way--
when I smush it up like that.
It looks kind of similar.
So if we look at the
higher mag picture,
again, these four images are
the same area of the cells.
And if you look at that
a little bit of crud,
it's the same on all
four of them there.
So this is the unloaded one.
And these were loaded
from top to bottom.
And this is loaded to some
extent/ that's loaded more,
and that's loaded more.
So if you look at
this cell here,
it's got this little tear on it.
So you can sort
of find it again.
If you look at that
cell there, that's
what it looks like unloaded.
And here you can see--
see that wall there?
You can see how it's bent up.
So it's bent like
the honeycomb walls.
And here it's bent even more.
And eventually, it has
this sort of a shape here,
and it's deformed permanently.
It's formed one of
these plastic hinges.
So it's like the aluminum
honeycombs almost,
that it's filled like that.
So in the balsa
wood, when we load it
in the tangential
direction, we're
getting bending of the cell
walls and then yielding
and plastic hinges forming,
just the same as we
would in an aluminum honeycomb.
Are we good with that?
Well, I'll go through
all three directions.
And then I'll write
down the notes.
So this is loading the balsa
in the radial direction.
And these things
here are the rays.
So we're loading it
in that direction.
And here you see this
also bending occurs,
but the rays act a little
bit like fiber reinforcement.
So the rays are a
little bit stiffer,
and they sort of
reinforce the thing a bit.
And this is the
loading platten here,
and you can kind of see that the
failure starts at the loading
platten, and as you
sort of load up more,
it progresses in from
the loading platten.
So we're going to
look at the modeling
of the balsa in the
radial direction,
and we're going to count for the
rays, at least in a crude way.
And then when you load them
balsa in the axial direction,
initially you don't
really see much happening.
So if one is unloaded,
one's down here.
And two is at this
peak stress up here.
And really, if you look
between one and two,
you just don't see an
awful lot of difference.
And that's because what you're
doing is you're taking the wood
and you're loading
it this way on.
And it's so stiff, you just
don't see much deformation.
So there's not
really much to see.
But then eventually,
something starts to fail.
And in this case, what
fails are the end caps.
So the balsa wood has
these long cells here.
But then at the
end of the cells,
there's little caps on the ends.
And the cells kind of
fit together like that.
So that eventually, if
you keep smushing it,
those end caps start to fail.
Here you can see
how bright it gets,
and the cells are starting to
crush together and kind of fail
those end caps.
And in fact, each one of
these serrations here,
if you look at,
say, from that peak
up to that peak,
that corresponds
to a length of about
the length of the cell,
or the length of the cell
between the end caps.
So in axial
deformation you're just
actually deforming the cells
until you break those end caps.
If you look at
denser words, they
fail in slightly different ways.
This is a Douglas fir,
which is much denser.
This particular
specimen, the whole thing
is kind of buckled over.
So it's not really
so representative
of the structure itself.
This is Douglas fir
in radial compression.
You can see this
picture, it looks just
like what I showed you for
the balsa wood, that sort
of propagation of the failure.
These long things
here are the rays.
And this is a Norway spruce
in axial compression.
And this is fairly
common in denser words.
You get this buckling formation.
And what happens
is, I think, you
get some yielding of the
cell walls initially,
but that leads to buckling,
like a plastic buckling.
And you can see on this
higher mag picture down here,
you get these really
small wavelength buckles
in the cell wall.
And the two-- you
get a plane that kind
of shears over itself.
And you can see
in the top image,
this top half has shared over
relative to the bottom half.
And all the deformation is
in this little band here.
So this stuff here is all
going on in that band up there.
So let me write down
some notes about how
these things to form and fail.
And then we'll get to the
modeling in little bit.
So we can say the
stress-strain curves
resemble those for honeycombs.
And I'll say the mechanisms
of deformation and failure
are most easily identified
in low density balsa wood.
So for balsa, if we look
at the tangential loading,
we see bending of the cell walls
and then eventually plastic
yielding.
And for radial loading, the
rays act as reinforcing.
And for axial loading, you
get axial deformation and then
the failure of the end caps.
And I'll just say failure
by plastic buckling
is also observed, say,
in the denser woods.
[INAUDIBLE]
So then we can look at some data
for the properties of woods.
And these charts plot relative
Young's modulus and relative
strength against
relative density.
So here the modulus
of the wood is
divided by the modulus of
the solid cell wall material.
And here we've
normalized everything
by the modulus of
the solid cell wall
material in the axial
direction, because the cell
wall itself is anisotropic.
And so here's the
relative modulus,
and here's the relative density.
These are log-log plots.
And we see that when we load
the wood in the axial direction,
the moduli is just linearly
related to the density.
And when we load it
across the grain,
it varies with the cube
of the relative density.
So do you remember our
little honeycomb models?
If I took the honeycomb
and I loaded it this way,
it went as the cube of T over L.
And that's because the bending.
And so the wood doesn't lie
perfectly on that cube line,
but it's fairly close.
And then similarly, if
we took the honeycomb
and we loaded it this way
on, it deformed axially.
The modulus depended
linearly on the density.
So you get the same kind
of relationships there.
And then if you look
at the strength,
the strength along the
grain goes linearly,
and the strength across the
grain goes with the square.
And we'll see when we get
to the modeling in a minute,
that if we loaded, say, an
aluminum honeycomb this way on,
the strength would go
linearly with the density,
if we're just yielding
the cell walls.
And if we loaded it this way
on, it went as the square of T
over L. So these things
kind of correspond.
And you can see the
structure of the wood
is a lot more complicated
than just a simple honeycomb.
And so these models are
sort of first order,
and they're fairly crude.
They don't try to capture every
detail of the wood structure.
But they can give you a sense
of where the wood properties are
coming from.
So let me just write down
some of these observations.
So the data for the wood--
the modulus along the grain
goes linearly with density.
It goes more or less
as the cube for loading
in the tangential direction.
And the radial direction is
somewhat stiffer different
than that.
The strength in
the axial direction
goes linearly with the density.
And the strength
across the grain
goes with the square
of the density.
And then there's data for
the Poisson's ratios too.
So let me just write them down.
So the modeling based
on the honeycomb
is sort of a
simplified model that
gives you kind of a first-order
description of the behavior.
And it doesn't really
attempt to capture
all the details of the softwood
and hardwood structure.
And in the equations, I'm
going to take the cell wall
properties along the grain,
or along the axial direction.
And we're going to have a bunch
of constants that describe
the cell geometry,
and those constants
are also going to reflect
the cell wall anisotropy.
So we can model
the wood structure
as something that's a bit more
of a simplified thing, just
like this.
And we say we've got cells
that are roughly hexagonal,
and then we've got
some cells that
are more or less rectangular
that are the ray cells.
And if you look at
lots of micrographs,
you can get some idea what the
dimensions of the cells are.
And these dimensions
were measured
for a particular
density of balsa wood.
So if we look at the
linear elastic moduli,
we can start off with
a tangential loading.
And if we have the
tangential loading,
we can model it as a
honeycomb loaded in the plane,
and we get cell wall bending.
And from the cell wall bending
in the honeycomb model,
you would get that the
tangential modulus varies
with the relative density cubed.
And the structure's
not quite that simple.
There's ray cells.
There's end caps.
And they act to stiffen
it a little bit.
And the data lie a little
bit above this line.
Then if we look at
the radial loading,
the rays kind of line up
with the radial direction,
and the rays act as
reinforcing plates.
And so you can just use kind of
an upper-bound composites idea
to get the modulus.
And the rays tend to be a
bit denser than the fibers.
So if I say a Vr is the
volume fraction of rays,
and R is the ratio of
the relative density
of the rays compared
to the fibers,
so it's rho over rho S for the
rays divided by rho over rho
S for the fibers.
And that varies a little
bit from what one species
to another, one
specimen to another.
But it's something a little over
1, something between 1 and 2.
Then I can say the modulus
in the radial direction
is the volume fraction
of the rays times
R cubed times the
tangential modulus plus 1
minus the volume
fraction of rays
times the tangential modulus.
And that works out
to be about 1.5
times the tangential modulus.
I wanted to work
this out in terms
of the tangential
modululs, so I've
put this in terms of
the tangential modules
in the first term there.
So we get that
the radial modulus
is slightly larger
than the tangential,
but also goes roughly as
the cube of the density.
And then for the
axial loading, we just
have axial deformation
in the cell wall.
And the Young's modulus
just varies linearly
with the density.
So these are kind
of simple models,
but they kind of
explain to first order
the density dependence of the
wood moduli and the anisotropy.
So it's kind of nice because
they're fairly simple models,
and it gives you kind
of a big picture.
So if you wanted to know the
modulus of a particular piece
of wood, this probably isn't
the best way to figure it out.
But if you wanted
to kind of compare
how do woods behave in general
and how does the density affect
the properties and why
are they anisotropic,
this is a pretty
good way to do it.
We could also look at
the Poisson's ratios.
And just because I didn't
want to write them down again,
I've just left on what
the data were down here.
But let me just write what
the model would give us
for nu RT and nu TR, the
model would give us one
if we had regular
hexagonal cells.
And these are the
values we get here.
This might be 0.6, 0.7 would
be a typical value, somewhere
around 0.4 in there, so
they're not quite one,
but they're close to it.
And I think the reason
they're a little less
is because the rays in the end
caps provide some constraint.
If you have the honeycomb,
if I just had these cells,
and I squeeze it like this,
these guys can move out.
If it's a regular
hexagonal honeycomb,
the strain that
I'm applying here
is equal to the strain
going out that way.
But if I have rays this way
that sort of constrain it or end
caps, it means that
the Poisson's ratio is
going to be a little bit less.
So I'll just say constraining
effect of the end caps
and rays-- constraining.
Then for nu RA and
nu TA, the model
says the value we would
get would be zero.
And these are pretty
close to zero.
They're not quite
zero, but pretty close.
And then the last
pair nu AR and nu AT,
the model says that we
would get nu of the solid.
And the data's close to
0.4, which we might expect
would be about the
nu of the solid.
So, again, there's
some variation
in the Poisson's ratios.
They're not all just one number.
But you can see these
ones here are about zero,
and that's roughly
what the model says.
These ones here are closer to 1.
And then these ones
here are closer
to what you might expect
for a solid material.
So it gives you the
kind of general idea.
Are we good?
We're good, yeah?
So we can do a similar thing
for the compressive strength.
So for tangential loading,
we get plastic hinges forming
and the bent cell walls, just
like in an aluminum honeycomb.
Then we get that the strength
over the cell wall strength
goes as the relative
density squared,
so just like the honeycomb.
the radial loading, we can do
the composites thing again.
So we can say the strengths
in the radial direction
is about equal to the
volume fraction of rays
times R squared times the
tangential strength plus 1
minus the volume
fraction of rays
times the tangential strength.
And for balsa, I have
some values here.
VR is about equal to 0.14.
R is about equal to 2.
And so the radial strength
is about equal to 1.4
times the tangential.
And in higher density
woods, the value of R
is a little bit smaller, and
in general, the radial strength
is a bit larger
than the tangential,
and both depend on
the density squared
And then for axial
loading, if the failure's
initiated by yielding
in the cell walls,
then the axial strength's
just going to depend linearly
on the density.
So the idea with
these models isn't
that they kind of describe
a particular piece of wood
exactly.
It's more that it gives you
a general picture of how
the cells are
deforming and failing,
and how the properties
scale with density
and why the wood's anisotropic.
Are we good?
Yeah?
Caught up.
So there are a couple more
sort of interesting things
we can do with looking
at the wood properties.
So we've been talking
about how to model
the cellular structure.
But people have also looked
at how to model the cell
wall as a fiber composite.
And this plot and the
next one kind of show you
how you can combine
all of that together.
So remember, I said the
modulus of the cellulose
was around 140 gigapascals.
So here's the modulus of
the cellulose, at least
the crystalline part of
the cellulose plotted
in that little envelope there.
The lignin and the hemicellulose
have a modulus around 2 or 3
gigapascals, so it's down there.
And if you made composites
with cellulose fibers
in lignin and
hemicellulose matrix,
those composites would
have a modulus that
fell in this envelope here.
They've got to be in between
those two limits, right?
The modulus have to be
between those two limits.
The density have to be
within the densities
of the constituents.
And if you look at the
modulus of the wood cell wall,
it lies in this envelope here.
Along the grain it'd be here,
and then across the grain
is further down here.
So the cell wall
modulus is in here.
And then if you
take that cell wall
and you make it into the
honeycomb-type material
that wood is, if you
load it along the grain,
you're going to get this
linear dependence of modulus
on density.
And if you load it
across the grain
in the radial or the
tangential direction,
you're going to get this
cubed dependence here.
So here's a set of data
for different woods
of different densities.
And that envelope kind of
encompasses all of them.
But if you look at the
slope of that data,
it's roughly equal
to a slope of 1.
And so it corresponds
to that equation there.
And similarly,
here's a set of data
for different species of woods
of different densities loaded
perpendicular to the grain.
And they lie on a line that
has more or less a slope of 3.
And this set of data
here along the grain
intersects the wood cell
wall towards the top
of that envelope,
and this set of data
here intersects closer to
the bottom of that envelope
for the cell wall material.
So this gives you a way of sort
of putting everything together
on one plot-- the cell wall as
well as the cellular structure.
So that plot does
it for the modulus.
And you can do the same kind
of thing for the strength.
Here's the cellulose up here.
Here's the lignin down there.
Here's the wood cell wall, the
composite made from those two.
And then here's data
for different kinds
of woods loaded along the grain
and for load across the grain.
So it gives you a way of
putting all this modeling
into one set of plots.
So let me just write a couple
of little things about that.
So we could say you could
model the cell wall as a fiber
composite.
And you can use the composition
upper and lower bounds
to give an envelope.
And then you can also show
the cellular solids models
on the same plot.
So overall, it shows you how
the hierarchical structure fits
together and can be modeled.
Now there's some more
cute things we can see.
So another thing I
want to talk about
is material selection,
because it turns out
wood is very good compared
to other materials
in certain applications.
So we're going to
look at, say, having
a beam of a given
stiffness at a given span,
and say it's just a
square cross-section beam
of edge length T.
And the question
is, what material would
minimize the mass of the beam?
So say we have some
span we have to have.
It's got to have some
rectangular cross-section,
some given stiffness.
And the question is,
what's the material
that minimizes the mass?
So there's a little
short calculation
we can do to figure that out.
And then I've got
another plot, and you
can compare different
materials on this other plot.
Then you'll see how good wood
is compared to other materials.
So from beam of a given
stiffness and given span,
and say it's a
square cross-section,
then the question
is, what material
minimizes the mass of the beam?
So the mass is just
going to be the density
times t squared
times l And if it's
a beam, say it's got
some central load on it,
a concentrated load,
the deflection's going
to go as pl cubed
divided by some constant
and divided by the Young's
modulus and the moment
of inertia I.
So the stiffness, if I just
rearrange this, the stiffness,
p over delta, that's going
to go as p over delta CEI,
and I's going to go as t
to the fourth over l cubed.
And then I can solve
that for t squared.
And I want t squared because
I'm going to plug it back
into the equation for the mass.
So if I solve this
for t squared,
I've got my stiffness
p over delta.
I've got l cubed divided by CE.
And then I take that whole thing
to the 1/2 power like that.
And then I plug
the t squared back
into the little
equation for the mass.
So I've got density minus p over
delta times l cubed over CE.
And we'll take that whole thing
to the 1/2 power-- [INAUDIBLE]
another l.
And so to minimize
the mass, you want
to look at the
material properties.
And here, the
material properties
are the density and
the Young's modulus.
And to minimize the mass,
you want to minimize rho
over E the 1/2 power.
Or conversely, you want to
maximize E to the 1/2 over rho.
So if you just had a bar that
you were just pulling on,
you would just want to
maximize E over rho.
But if it's a beam
and bending, it
works out that you want to
maximize E to the 1/2 over rho.
And if we look at the next
slide, this next slide then
plots on a log-log scale,
it plots the modulus
on this axis and the
density on that axis.
And here this plotted data for
lots of different materials.
So there's engineering alloys.
Metals are up here.
Engineering ceramics are here.
Composites are here.
Polymers are down here.
Elastomer is way down here.
Foamy things, down here.
And this envelope here is woods.
And notice log scale here.
The lowest stiffness polymer
foams here are 0.1 gigapascal,
and diamond is up here
at 1,000 gigapascal.
So there's like five orders
of magnitude difference
in the modulus here.
So then, if you look at the
bottom right corner here,
there's a bunch of
old dashed lines.
And this red one here is
E to the 1/2 over rho.
So if it's log-log plot,
E to the 1/2 over rho's
going to show up
as a straight line.
And every point on that
line has the same value of E
to the 1/2 over rho.
And the material that would be
the best for a beam of a given
stiffness would be the one
that has the biggest value of E
to the 1/2 over rho.
And if I move the line
up to the top left here,
I'm increasing E.
I'm decreasing rho.
It's got the biggest value
of E to the 1/2 over rho.
So the materials that
are on this line here,
they all have the same value
of E to the 1/2 over rho.
And they've got the biggest
value-- well, virtually
the biggest value.
So let's look at what
those materials are.
There's things like
engineering ceramics,
like diamond that maybe are
not the most convenient thing
to make our beam
out of, and tend
to be brittle and might break.
So we have some issues.
There's engineering composite,
so things like carbon fiber
reinforced plastics.
And at this sort of
tip of the composites,
there'd be things like
unidirectional fiber
composites.
And then here's other
woods down here.
So the woods have the
same performance index,
this is called,
the same value of E
to the 1/2 over rho as the
best engineering composites.
And so they have very good
properties for their weight.
And one of the
interesting things
is if you look at this
performance index of E
to the 1/2 over rho, this is the
performance index for the wood.
This is for the solid
cell wall material
that the wood's made from,
so E to the 1/2 of the solid
over rho for the solid.
And from the
modeling of the wood,
just looking at
the axial modulus,
this thing here is equal to
that times rho S over rho.
So if you look at this, this
is the performance index
for the wood.
This is the solid
it's made from.
This number here is
bigger than 1, right?
Because the density
of the solid is
bigger than the
density of the wood,
and so this is
saying the wood is
more efficient than
the thing that it's
made from, than the solid
that it's made from.
And so that's the sort of
plot for the stiffness.
And there's a similar
plot for the strength.
That if you do the same
little kind of calculation,
you find that the performance
index for the strength
is some failure strength raised
to the 2/3 power over a rho.
And again, here we're plotting
strength versus density
on a log-log plot.
And this red line here is the
strength of the 2/3 over rho.
And again, if we scoot over
here so we have a parallel line,
every point on that line has
the same value of the strength
to the 2/3 power
over the density.
And these are the materials
that have the highest values.
And again, here's
engineering composites.
These are ceramics.
But the ceramics, they have
a high compressive strength,
but they tend to be brittle.
So it's not really a
practical strength.
These are metals in here.
And here's the woods down here.
So it's kind interesting
just to see that the wood has
such a good property.
Yes?
STUDENT: So I realize why
this is valuable setting up
the problem this way.
But if you're actually trying
to design something, why would
you want to fix
your cross-section?
You could change your material
and change your cross-section.
LORNA GIBSON: So this
is the starter version
of this problem.
And there's another
part two of the problem
is to change the shape.
And you could look at
what shape's efficient.
There's something called
a shape factor that
gives you the efficient shapes.
So you could take the
material and turn it
into a different shape and
have a more efficient thing
because it was a
different shape.
So you can account for that.
STUDENT: So then
if you varied, like
let's say you made your
cross-section smaller,
like even if it
was still square,
you could just still
make it smaller.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
I'm saying we've got
a given stiffness.
So if we're given a certain
stiffness and a certain span,
we would need a
certain cross-section
to get to that stiffness.
Are we happy?
OK.
So that's one thing.
Let's see here.
So let me just write a few
more notes about the material
selection, and then there's
one more thing I wanted
to show you about the woods.
Hmm?
C is just a constant.
So it's just a number.
So if you had a beam
in three-point bending,
then C would be three.
If you had a beam
that was simply
supported with a central
load, C would be 48.
C is just a number.
STUDENT: One more question.
So follow your line
there, and the choice
is really just about cost.
LORNA GIBSON: No,
it's not about cost.
There's nothing on cost here.
It's all really
about the properties.
What's the best
combination of properties
to minimize the mass, and
then which material has
that combination of properties.
You can do charts like
this that include cost.
You can make these charts
with whatever property.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
I guess maybe there's a
difference off two or so
of strength.
LORNA GIBSON: Between
pine and balsa?
Yeah, maybe more than that.
I think-- I can't quite see
where-- pine's close to 100,
and balsa's, I don't
know, 20 or something.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, and
it's not-- the point of this
isn't so much looking at the
absolute value of a strength.
It's looking at the value
of this performance index.
And what you want to do
is maximize that index
to get the material that's
going to minimize the mass.
So let me just read a
couple notes about this.
So we have these-- these are
called material selection
charts.
So you plot the log of one
property versus the log
of some other property.
And then we have a line of
constant E to the 1/2 over rho.
I'll just say it's shown
in red because you're
going have the same plots.
And the materials with
the largest values
are in the upper left.
So the woods have similar values
to engineering composites.
And you can do a similar
thing for strength.
So I have a few more minutes.
So I have a few minutes, and
I want to talk about a couple
of uses of woods.
So one is in old ships.
So I don't know if you
know Professor Lechtman has
this course Materials
and the Human Experience,
and they talk about sort of
ancient uses of materials.
And I did a section,
a module, on woods
and the use of woods
in old colonial ships,
like The Constitution
that's in Boston Harbor.
So this is kind of a
schematic of an old ship.
And the thing that
was interesting
and the thing I talked
about in this module
was that people chose particular
species for particular parts
of the boat.
And they would choose
a particular species
depending on its properties.
And a lot of the
hull was made of oak.
So oak's a very dense wood.
But they would get something
they called straight oak,
and they would get something
they called compass oak.
And you can see this
little thing down here,
this little kind of schematic
here, this little sketch.
This is straight oak,
just a straight trunk.
And this thing here
would be the compass oak.
And what they would do is they
would use the straight oak
for straight parts of
the boat, so something
like this, these pieces here.
And then they
would actually look
for trees that had the
curve of the branches
to match some part of the boat
that they were looking for.
So, for instance, if you have
the hull out here and the deck
here and they had
their cannons here,
there's something
called a knee, which
is sort of a bracing
piece that goes
between the deck and the hull.
And that bracing
piece is curved.
And they would
actually look for trees
in which the branches curved
at the same kind of curvature
as they were looking
for in that piece.
And then they would
use it for that piece.
And the advantage of
this is they basically
had the grain running
along the curve,
and so they got the best
properties out of the wood
by doing that.
So they had this straight
oak and compass oak,
and that was one cute thing.
And often they used white oaks.
And I brought a piece
of white oak in.
You can see how dense it is.
And the US Navy often used
something called live oak.
Live Oak grows in the South.
Anybody from the South?
You see these big
trees with huge sort
of spreading branches.
Those are the live oaks.
And apparently, the US
Navy, I read somewhere,
still has a forest
somewhere with live oak
for doing things like
repairing The Constitution.
So let me just pass
those guys around.
So those are a couple of oaks
they would use for the hull.
Then they would use
white pine for the masts.
And the reason they used
white pine for the mast
is because the white pine
grows very, very tall and very
straight.
And white pine was actually
like a strategic resource
in the 1600s, the 1700s.
And it turns out that when the
British Royal Navy was doing
all that colonial stuff
in the 1600 and 1700s,
Britain actually ran out of
trees for masts for boats,
and they would actually
import masts from New England.
And there were these
people called surveyors
who would go around
and they would
mark certain trees
that were supposed
to be saved for these masts
for the British Royal Navy.
And the thing was that
the size of the boat
and how many cannons you
could put on the boat depended
on how big the mast was.
So the size of the boat
depended on the mast,
because the mast height
controlled how much sail area
you could get.
So the taller the mast, the
more sail/ the more sail,
the bigger the ship.
The bigger the ship,
the more cannons.
And so having these
tall Eastern white pines
was a sort of a
strategic resource.
And I have a piece
of white pine.
Unfortunately, my
dog got to this one.
And be careful.
It's a bit splintery.
But you can see it's a
lighter kind of wood.
And if you go
around New England,
if you go to the arboretum,
you can see white oak.
You can see Eastern white pine.
The other wood they
used is lignum vitae,
that first dense one
that I passed around.
And if you notice that lignum
vitae has kind of a waxy
feel to it.
And they used that in the block
and tackle, so like pulleys
and stuff like that.
And it was thought to
be self-lubricating
because of that kind
of waxy layer on it.
And because it's very dense,
if you think of like a block
and tackle and you've got like
a rope going over a pulley,
you've got a pressure from
everything sort of fitting
together and the bits
bearing against each other.
And the fact that was very dense
made it very good for the block
and tackle.
And so they used the
lignum vitae for that.
And there's one other cute
story about lignum vitae.
I don't know if
any of you've ever
read Dava Sobel's Longitude.
Anybody read that?
I'm a sucker for those
history of science books.
So her book Longitude
is about the development
of an instrument to
measure longitude.
Originally, they could get
the latitude from the stars,
but they were really bad
at getting the longitude.
And so boats would go off,
and they wouldn't really
be able to figure
out where they were,
until they had a method
to measure longitude.
And there was some British
board of something or another.
They put forward a
prize for somebody
who could produce a way of
measuring longitude accurately.
And there was a guy called John
Harrison, and he built a clock.
He built a very
accurate chronometer.
And if you knew when sunrise
was and sunset was, and you knew
the time and where you left,
you could figure out where you--
it's kind of like time zones.
You could figure out
where you are today.
And he built a chronometer, and
one version of his chronometer
used a lignum vitae
for the same reason,
because it was very dense,
and it was very stable.
And the clock that he
eventually won the prize with
was in the 1700s, 1759.
I think they went on
some trip with it.
It was 81 days at sea, and it
lost five seconds over 81 days.
So that's pretty impressive
for 250 years ago.
So that was the lignum
vitae in the clock.
I have one more picture,
and then I can finish up
the thing on wood.
And we'll start
the cork next time.
So this is another
example of using wood.
And this is sort of
a more modern use.
So this bridge here is made
with a glue-laminated wood.
So this big beam
here, the big arch,
is made up of sections of
wood which are glued together.
And you can glue the sections
in a curved shape if you want.
They sort of have
molds to do that.
And when they make this
glue-laminated wood,
they cut the defects out.
So they cut knots
out, and they control
the pieces of each
laminate that they
use to get the best quality.
And the glue-laminated
wood actually
has better properties
than just two-by-fours
or whatever you would
cut down, lumber
that you would cut from a tree.
So glue-laminated wood is
kind of a nice kind of wood
structure that's used now.
And you see it all the time in
things like ice rink arenas,
like large spans.
It's kind of beautiful.
You can see the wood grain in
the curve in the wood grain
when they make these things.
So that's the wood lecture.
I'm going to stop there.
So next time I'll
talk about cork.
I just have a little
bit about cork.
And then we'll start
talking about foams.